what's the one that girls drink
mojito dude remember when girls figured
out that thing like [__] four years
ago they were just like wait there's the
mojitos
and then there they went nuts wait this
is how you you know why it's such a
growth drink because you can put so many
things in it dude you know what girls
love things girls love things
they straight up you know what guys guys
like I don't know
guys the guys I don't know whatever guys
like this is what guys like whatever
this is what girls love things dude if
you could hold the thing forget it dude
forget it tchotchkes you should see how
many [__] tchotchkes my mom has how
much is tchotchke sounds something like
it sounds like it's a racist thing is it
probably I have no idea I have no idea
all I know are tchotchkes are things and
if it's racist come get me babies I've
got no clue
uh
uh dude my mom's got so many charge keys
and then she's got the nerve when she's
done with the tchotchke to be like hey
Chris I got some stuff for you come put
this church key in your house
[__] [__] I got a whole closet
full of tchotchkes because of my mom
life's hard but what I'm saying is girls
love things and that's why my Thai's
[__] kick ass
give a girl oh you don't think girls
love things dude give your girl a bag
full of [__] [__] in it give your
girl a bag full of [__] things in it
watch her smile dude
she'll get chapped lips she'll smile so
hard she'll Smiles so hard that that
[__] [__] on the bottom of the middle
of her lip just goes and then all of a
sudden she's like I need chapstick and
you go check the bag because it's in
there because it's a thing
that's why girls love chapstick dude
they don't even like it why I like to
always keep my lip no they no you don't
you'll like it because it's a thing
that's why girls say [__]
let's fix up an old car it's so you get
the car and what do we need the parts
and oh we have good we have this stuff
let's not fix up the car I just really
wanted all the [__]
I'm surprised girls aren't hip to those
[__] glasses that come up like this
yet
they just like the real big ones because
it's more of a thing but you mark my
[__] words girls are gonna be wearing
those [__] in
by next summer uh you know what by the
end of this summer
I'm gonna put it out there girls are
gonna be wearing those flip up glasses
that [__] Corey Haim used to wear
I swear to God because it's the thing
because they've got two things now they
got this part and this part
it's amazing how much girls love things
and they do and that's not a [__]
sexist thing it's a [__] gatherer
thing a Haunter gatherer thing guys go
out and get the things and they bring
the things to the girl and the girls
[__] put it all in the house
wonder what the girl is who got the
first thing was
probably some [__] a a
big [__]
bunch of tied up sticks
it's weird how that's yeah a bunch of
tied up sticks
and then they were like oh you can burn
this and it makes a cool scent and the
guy's like what are you doing with that
thing I I you know let's use it for
firewood and he's like no no she's like
no it's for smelling and he's like
that's not a [__] what we mean
they're like it makes the Hut smell good
like all right
okay
good jewelry there you go bam
what do guys wear a tie or if and guys
don't want to guys are like I don't know
where the [__] tie we're gonna wear
the [__] tie
you see a guy who doesn't wear a tie
wear a tie you see his face bro have you
ever seen a guy's face who doesn't
usually wear a tie wearing a tie it
sucks
girls love to get dressed up though
let's do it
I mean not every girl you know but I'm
saying girls are like I mean weddings
girls are always like yeah we got to go
to wedding guys like [__] I gotta go
to goddamn North Dakota it's so dick for
anyone to get married for real nah it's
not dick to get married it's so dick to
have a wedding
God when guys are like yes sorry bro I
gotta get married
you gotta go you got calm where is it
Hawaii yeah I get no no that'll be a
good one where is it oh it's in [__]
Michigan dude what yeah her family's
from [__] Kalamazoo
so we're gonna have it over there
so 90 people are gonna have to go over
there that don't want to
so yeah
so I'm going to make all of my family go
to Kalamazoo
cause you know why
because girls like things
that's how much girls like things
they'll make you go to [__] Kalamazoo
because of how much they like things so
you got to go and You Gotta Dance the
Night Away dude
you gotta dance the night away and
you've got to trick yourself into ah you
know what this yeah yeah I had a good
time I didn't want to go but I I've got
there once I got there was you ever
talked to that guy [__] that [__] ass
dude
a real man goes like yo did you have fun
though was it fun a real man goes like
this nope didn't want to go was there
made the best of it because I'm a human
being and didn't want to [__] have to
jump
but it was fine because I made it fine
in my head
all from a girl
because she loves things and you know
what makes the world go around things
yeah man
I always thought about how girls like
things ever since I was a little kid I
would be like ghosts like things
I'd think about that [__]
what a weird [__] kid I must have
been man for real